in the united kingdom they're retiring
old patrol cars all just regular
run-of-the-mill cop cars to keep peace
on the streets they are retiring them
and replacing them
with rainbow colored
anti-hate crime cars
a police officer in the united kingdom
explains the move
the rainbow cars the hate crime cars
whatever we want to call them they are
part of our vehicle fleet so you know
we're always replacing vehicles they get
um all of the police sort of insignia
put on them as normal but there will
normally be then something added on that
is to do with the rainbow side of things
um but they're out there as normal
patrol vehicles sometimes people will
ask us how can you afford to do that you
know that's not right to to spend money
on putting a rainbow on a car well
actually the cost is quite minimal but
the confidence that it can bring by just
having that rainbow on there and people
say to me you know the impact of seeing
the rainbow is so huge and the idea is
that the cars are there in the
communities generally on normal policing
patrol just again to show the community
that we want you to come forward if
something is happening that you know
isn't right then we absolutely want you
to come forward so it is there to try
and give confidence to our lgbt plus
community but also to other
underrepresented groups and unless we
have an organization where all of our
staff feel that they can feel included
that they are included um i don't think
we can deliver the best service to our
communities
now i know that that was in another
language that was in
british so i i would like to translate
that for you into american
dear taliban
dear china
please come invade us
please we are no longer a serious people
we do not understand anything about our
society or criminal justice oh i'm
becoming a legislator freaking i don't
know my accent's not great this is
pathetic this is real this is like a
monty python sketch
this is
i want to be a woman you want to be a
woman i want to have babies this is
literally a monty python sketch
and now it is
police chiefs in the united kingdom
saying we're not going to focus on
real crime anymore we're not going to
focus on people you know stabbing you
and taking your property so
then at the philosophical level we're
not going to focus on the protection of
private property we're not going to
focus on the protection of our political
order and our political tradition
instead
we're going to focus on finding out
whether or not anyone in the community
has any
objection in their own mind or
conscience to men dressing up like women
and we're going to root that out because
transphobia is not that's not what we're
going to stand for here in the united
kingdom
you you before you go
hold on slow down
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your podcasts type in let's just hear me
out type in
the michael knowles show
hit search
it comes up they're probably going to
bury the results but it'll you know
it'll come up eventually subscribe
leave a five star review maybe leave a
comment here on youtube before you leave
i would appreciate it greatly it'll help
us get around some of the big tech stuff
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]